- I mean, what do you want to know?
("Tribal" by Warner/Chappell
Production Music)
- [Maya] My name is Maya Z.
The inventor of the selfie, perhaps.
The perfectionist of the selfie,
definitely.
I'm the name behind many
of the most selfies you've seen.
The great Ellen photograph of the Oscars.
Many of Kim Kardashian's.
You would closely and you
can see me in the background
directing it as if it were an orchestra.
- That's why I'm here.
'Cause she's the best.
Yeah, I've always wanted to
be popular and I know that
to be popular, it starts with Instagram.
- I followed her work
with the iPhone 4, 4S.
Oh, let's not forget about the 5 and 5S.
- How does it smell in here?
- Like
art.
- A good selfie.
My motto is know your selfie.
What does the background, the lighting,
the angle, what does it say about you?
My friend, Joshua, took a picture
with just a six pack and
he got like 500 likes
in 52 minutes, and he
changed his name to Viper.
I just kinda wanted what Viper has.
- My background is in
online dating selfies.
You know, the lowest form of
selfie and I just asked myself
what else is there?
- Can you please?
- Beautiful.
- Ah, thank you, but you're in it so.
Say, you see a rabbit
and you wanna catch that rabbit.
You are the rabbit. You are the trap.
You want to eat yourself for dinner.
That, and if nothing else
is truly the definition of
what it is to capture yourself.
- I was a busboy at Joe's
Crab Shack for two years
saving up so I could have
this experience with Maya Z.
I am very intimidated to
be working with Maya today,
but I'm also excited.
- On a good day, we walk out of the studio
with some amazing
selfies, and on a bad day,
I'll have to clean up a
lot of broken iPhone 6's.
- And no I will not
disclose which filters I may
or may not use.
I enjoy
Siena.
My cousin, not the filter.
- So how tall is she?
- Yes.
- Don't worry.
We'll use one of mine.
Four inches up.
One centimeter down.
[Maya] Ah, lower.
How many likes do you
want? How many likes?
- Like 25.
- 25?
- Am I looking through the
screen or into the camera?
- Look into your soul.
Go back to a happy place.
The date is July 4th, Independence Day.
A film starring Will
Smith, you went to see it
when it came out.
- [Maya] You bought a
popcorn with large butter.
You met a girl named
Brenda and you kissed her
at that theater.
Take your selfie.
- I don't even know her now.
- [Simon] It's perfect.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- [Maya] I know.
I know.
It will be $5,000.
When a photo is taken of you.
- Benard?
- [Maya] A piece of your soul is taken.
Have a great day.
- [Maya] But when you take a selfie,
you gain that piece of your soul back.
John Lennon.
("Tribal" by Warner/Chappell
Production Music)
- [Voiceover] Do you know what this is?
- Do I know what this is?
What is this? A back scratcher?
Thank you.
- [Voiceover] No, that's a selfie stick.
- It's a what? Is this a joke?
Is this being sold to children?
How would you feel if a man
with no arms saw you use
a selfie stick?
How do you think he'd feel?
Here's my selfie stick,
and here's my other one.